je vous présente les jumeaux craie en
âge des régionales ça vous plaît d'être
un gangster
ce qui me plaît c'est l'argent et le
respect mon frère et moi enfin m londres
à nos pieds
c'est quoi ce rouleau à pâtisserie
tu as à me faire une tarte la mafia a
posé des jalons landre va devenir le las
vegas de l'europe
on peut le gérer votre frère rhône et
violent et déséquilibré ouais non non
non non réglé le problème rom
c'est mon frère nous allons traquer les
jumeaux créé jusque dans les bas fonds
tu permets que je me défende tentant ce
que tu dis tu es saleh ont battu métier
de gangsters parce que c'est ce qu'on
l'est
ouais tu rigoles mois-là d'accous